greetings of peace welcome welcome
welcome to the dean show my next guest
faz apex is a 26 year old muslim
palestinian born and raised in
california
at the age of 14 he became a member of
the gaming group called faz clan
he has spent the last 11 years as a
pivotal member of the organization and
is one of the four original founders of
the business
he has since
transitioned out of the content creation
and into the leadership role in the
company
so faz apex our next guest is one of the
owners of the largest gaming
organizations in the world
and he's someone who also loves
something more than any
of these games let's find out what that
is here with apex
peace be with you assalamu alaikum this
is your brother hamza andreas
and i want every single one of you to
support eddie from the dean show
financially and otherwise but in what
way
i want you to support his new project
the dean center it's going to be a
transformative experience this center
why because it's going to be a masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a taoist
center to call people back to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala muslims and
non-muslims and we trust eddie
completely i for one will take a
thousand bullets for eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the tower he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many do art and preachers
and scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to thedeencenter.org donate
now
[Music]
like miss salam how are you doing how
you doing young man i'm delight doing
well thank you for having me on the show
appreciate it it's great to have you on
the show you said something in arabic
and some people are like
what's uh they heard habib say it they
hear you saying it now what's this
alhamdulillah what does that mean oh
praise and thanks to the
allah or god the most high so
that's beautiful alhamdulillah yeah
so you'll hear us saying that a lot yeah
so what's this uh faz this fast clan
talk to us about that phase clan space
clan is the name we are a gaming
organization uh like you mentioned i uh
started off as like kind of a group of
kids that just played video games
together um and i joined uh the group
when i was 14 2011 and since then um
with the rest of the gaming industry
it's kind of grown into a business and a
thing a lot larger than than just that
and now um
you know we're one of the leading
organizations in the gaming esports
world and i'm de la blessed to be one of
the founders and uh
one of the people kind of helping run it
and put it on the right path so um yeah
we just we do a lot of things we have a
lot of professional gamers that play in
i think we have up to eight different
games that people play in and then we
have a whole another roster of uh twitch
streamers and youtube uh and tick tock
content creators and stuff so
do a couple things we got a couple
athletes now that we have recently
brought on to our team as well so we're
kind of just like a youth culture uh
internet
you know little group trying to just
take over the internet so
who are these athletes you're talking
about uh so right now we have uh uh
bronnie james lebron james jr has joined
uh is a member we have uh
kyler murray who was a quarterback on
the arizona cardinals uh
oh man i'm gonna you could put me on the
spot i'm gonna forget some of the other
guys uh
that's all right if it doesn't come down
i mean we've worked with a lot of
different athletes but those two are
actual like solidified phase members i
mean recently actually snoop dogg music
artist who signed so
you know we have we have poop doggy
doggy yeah so we have we have a a wide
uh you know a group of people hamdullah
that have been a part of it so so you do
you get to uh are you gonna get to meet
snoop dogg yeah so i did meet him i mean
when i recorded a video with him he's a
really really good guy
at his little like warehouse he has so
hopefully he can take some of this
advice that we're going to be
giving out now and this is from your
trip hajj right yeah so i want to read
this i want to go ahead and because this
is what we're going to be talking about
something that you love more than any
other games so
this is i believe this is this is you
this is no blessing in the
in life compares to the blessing of
being and i'm going to just define this
term one who has submitted to the will
of the creator that heavens and earth
muslim nothing gives you more peace and
purpose in this world inshallah god
willing we all will be reunited together
in the next life in the highest levels
of jannah paradise now this is a
beautiful advice you're saying here at
the end i highly encourage anyone
who has any interest or feels like they
are missing a purpose in life to look
into
islam submission to the creator not the
creation may god guide us all to the
best
for us in this life and the next what
was going through your mind
you're in front of the first house of
worship built by emma uh by abraham to
commemorate the worship of one and only
one god and you're given this wonderful
advice what's going i mean what's what
are you feeling at the time yeah
i've been blessed to be able to visit
mecca medina a couple times
alhamdulillah and when i posted that uh
i think i just got back from a trip
there and uh honestly i talked about
i've talked about a couple times recent
the past couple years but so i i like i
mentioned i joined faze when i was 14 so
i've been kind of online creating
content since i was a 14 year old and
over that last 11 year i just turned 26
yesterday actually i'm the last so like
it's been 11 years of me doing this and
not until really the last maybe two or
three years have i really kind of um
realized the platform you know that i've
been blessed with to
uh
share you know the message of islam and
also like you know shine some light on
things that happen among around the
world and kind of using my platform for
good so when i joined originally i was
kind of you know i grew up in america my
whole life so i was kind of uh i don't
want to say bullied i don't want to like
make it i wasn't bullied you know not
not to make it sound worse than it was
but there was a guy in the organization
who was like the biggest at the time i
compared to like let's say for all the
football fans out there i don't say
soccer
that let's say you join uh
you know barcelona at the time and
you're the biggest messi fan when he was
on barcelona and then he's like making
fun of you for being arab and muslim or
whatever that's what happened to me so
as a 14 year old that happened
right off the bat since then i kind of
just really kept to myself didn't really
speak on my background my religion
nothing like that um and then in the
last couple years i realized like it's
you know
it's not only nothing to be ashamed of
but it's something to be super proud of
so
um
and at the end of the paragraph you read
as well with you know people i've seen a
lot of people the reason i put that in
about people not really having a purpose
in life i'm that i've met so many people
so many successful people over the last
couple years and
it's crazy to me to see
uh like
you know off camera how people's lives
are you know all the people that have
all the success in the world and people
think that they would probably be the
happiest people in the world like i see
so many people that just feel like
they're missing something and i truly
think that that's what it is it's like
you said connection with the one god
with the you know submission to you've
phrased it perfectly to the creator not
the creation and i'm de la i know i just
i feel like there's a um obligation on
me to
spread it you know and i'm that's what i
try to do i i obviously i'm focusing on
working on myself first and foremost
trying to be the best muslim i can be
but like it's not even it's it's really
it
like that post specifically is really
like
you guys need it like there's people out
there that need it and like you know
people haven't been exposed
to certain things and
i was just you know feeling great coming
back from mecca alhamdulillah and i
thought i would post it so it's awesome
even i just saw the likes on it right
now too like obviously i don't post it
for likes but it's crazy to me a lot to
see the engagement on it is better than
any of the engagement i've on any of my
other posts that i've posted recently it
might be the most liked picture i've
posted which is crazy
and really just showed me too like um
for the muslim world kind of i feel like
all right i got a little bit of a voice
here that i got to use inshallah for the
right reasons so it was good to see
mashaallah that's what i'm talking about
so nothing to be you realize it was
nothing to be ashamed of but something
to be proud of it's the way of jesus
it's the way of moses abraham the last
final message prophet muhammad this is
the same way of life that they lived
islam submission to one god to the will
of god this is something that i've had
you have iced tea
you had i've had freeway
on part of jc's crew you had loon uh
amir mujer hadith uh
stephen jackson stephen jackson stack
you heard it yeah of course and many of
these people they're also coming to
islam you know when your mind is open
and what do you think like since you
mentioned some of these other
celebrities some of these other athletes
like snoop doggy dog how receptive
because at one point i think he was
going towards the nation
yeah i i have a memory in my head as
well i was like you remember that seeing
him like
something seem dressed up maybe in like
some traditional clothing or something
but yeah
that's the thing to have noticed you
know
the nation obviously is like a path has
been a path for some people towards
you know the the
i guess yeah i will say the true islam
because i've actually looked more into
the nation recently and i've really seen
the differences i never knew until
recently but you know like yeah
subhanallah i think
a lot of people kind of have a lot of
celebrities and a lot of uh
athletes and stuff have seemed to go
down that route and as we saw muhammad
ali and malcolm x that led them to
of course them but yeah it's you know i
i think actually more than ever people
are more i mean at least in our
generation right compared to the last
the last let's just say 100 years it
seems like so many people are are not
only converting i know you probably see
more than i do it's on social media
i see so many people talking about their
their path to islam and like i just feel
a lot of people are really open-minded
um we have a lot of amazing role models
like khabib who have like really
shined a bright beautiful light on like
what it is to be a muslim um obviously
muhammad ali as well as one of the most
influential figures
in islam in the last couple in the last
hundred years at least then like um yeah
i think it's great when we have athletes
and people that
that well known that
embody what an actual muslim is as well
you know like like habib
that's why people that's he's opened the
door for so many people convert because
his actions and his character which you
know i'm sure he tries to resemble the
prophet saws and
he does an amazing job at being you know
acting like a muslim so
those are the things that i think open
people's eyes especially in
a culture where
everybody's focused on themselves and
focus on material and stuff like that
that when you see someone like khabib
who like doesn't care about anything but
god and his family and doing what he
does like
it's a little weird to people and it
kind of like
it catches them off guard it makes them
want to look into it so like
we
it's the best way to live by example so
i just think like this next generation
of athletes like
and and celebrities i really think like
we're going to keep seeing more and more
i know you've mentioned a lot there's a
lot of other athletes as well that have
converted and i just think it's uh it's
interesting it's just interesting to see
the spread of islam right now amongst
like mainstream media so it's cool
yeah you it reminds me of when the
prophet muhammad peace and blessed be
upon him he made dua
supplication for the two omars you don't
have them to accept islam
and this
dua reached and we see the impact when
umar radhilahan when he accepted islam
so when some of these figures you
imagine you know the following that they
have
and how many people are glued you know
imitating them watching them and when
they turn towards the right path they
can really do some amazing good
and
benefit from any of the things that
you're talking about there's a quote
here
that you said and it's very powerful i
want you to elaborate on this you said
there's no chance in earth no elon musk
or anyone
to have me take a drink of alcohol and
we see you know problems we just saw
johnny depp you don't have to know much
about him but it was all over you know
the circus their their lives were just
plastered all over and he would for
instance may god almighty allah guide
him and amber to the to the truth to
islam but you can see alcohol played a
big major role
in the problems that were happening he
was waking up in the morning drinking
you know happy hour all throughout the
day but imagine like this is uh
what gave you this discipline to
say something like that where not even
elon musk can
i don't even don't know i'm not sure
where that quote's from but it sounds
sounds right though i i yeah
that was you as a quote from you yeah i
know i'm saying i don't it's funny i
don't even i don't remember saying that
but definitely i'm dylan like
i definitely live by that like i'm very
happy to say that i've never even taken
a sip like you said never dabbled into
that drugs any of that stuff and for me
it's been pretty easy i think i think
just um
i don't know for some people you know it
just sets in easier to their brains like
all right this is bad i'm not gonna do
it and like i've just
you know alcohol i've never been really
tempted towards
uh even drugs like nothing like that
have ever really interested me but a lot
of people around me especially in my
scene that i'm in with work partake in
drinking and smoking and stuff like that
and
i've just really seen the the negatives
to it i haven't really seen any
positives i mean it's funny like a lot
of my old roommates and stuff like would
always tell me like man i understand why
you don't drink and like i respect why
you don't drink and why you don't smoke
and why this and that and it's just the
funny because i'm like it's not me it's
just it's my religion it's i'm just
following it and like you know it's it's
and even gambling too is another thing
but like i've just seen these things
happen and like yeah in the moment
that's the one thing i can't lie
gambling is something that man
hamdulillah because i would be an addict
if it wasn't and like i know that and
like i could see why it's haram and i
could you could see the wisdom in it
just like the wisdom and um alcohol and
you know everything else being but yeah
it's
been pretty simple for me i think in the
household i was raised in and also my
community and like the friends that i
grew up around
most of my my closest friends come from
the masjid so like
we all have the same you know
we all have have the same morals we all
follow the same like you know we're all
muslim we all follow we all we all go
about life the same so like it was
pretty simple it's never really
pressured
down the path of any of those things and
it's just just easy for me to stay away
from that allah put it in me to not
really be tempted by those things and
like
you know i've had some opportunities
with sponsorships and
with with with
alcohol brands and gambling brands and
all those things and i'm
you know just again growing up my mom
always tell me
uh you know that when you when you leave
something for allah you'll be give some
be given something better or when you
stay away from something like a lower
place with better and i've seen that
alhamdulillah happen in my life and it's
just
it's like it's not even a question for
me like
i'm always able to stay away from these
things and and uh not dabble into
anything bad but like that gray line to
me i never really even try to get near
it so like i'm dilla it's it's it's it's
not something too difficult for me to
allah says it's haram i try to do my
best to stay away from it
you know how many parents right now or
not just parents just individuals out
there they're like i wish i could stay
away from alcohol yeah i know and i wish
i could go ahead and just leave this
alone they're seeing the disaster that's
happening in their lives due to this but
you know this is amazing to have someone
as young as you
to be sometimes you know around some
very influential people and peer
pressure i know how that works if you're
around you know uh if you don't have a
strong foundation you're not solid you
know you can bend and one just one time
it needs to be that one sip that one
buzz
and that's all she wrote no yeah
unfortunately it's a real addiction like
that's something people don't really
understand either it's like a lot of
people can't help themselves so like may
allah help anyone who's going through it
um even if maybe at one point they made
the conscious decision to take part in
that stuff like it's not the easiest
thing in the world to stop and uh i
think like
i don't know sometimes you have other
experiences where you get a little you
look at a little taste of what they
might be feeling in their bodies and
it's easy to understand i know it's it
it's something they can't control you
know a lot of people can't control it
and it's a tough thing and everyone has
their tests alhamdulillah you know for
me it hasn't been been tested with and
shall i never am tested with it and like
you said anyone that is inshallah
they're able to
you know overcome those temptations
but this is the antidote what we started
off with in your post islam this is it
this is for all the social ills you know
people why at the end of the day look
apex why should i give it up for what
they're if if i'm not believing in
something greater than myself living for
a true purpose if i'm just
there you know fulfilling my desires
what's the point of you know it all at
the end of the day and why should i
really stop you know what i mean i'm not
looking for something higher but you are
obviously and that's where would you say
that's is that where the discipline you
know the self-discipline really kicked
in because of islam no of course
of course
like
it again like i blessed to be born
muslim to grow up amongst muslims to
just always be raised with that
mentality because like
you know i'm 26 i don't know if i wasn't
if i didn't grow up in a family that was
even quote unquote religious or part of
a community or whatever i don't know
what my life would be like but for me
it's not even a question like these
things are things that i've known since
i was young that i've learned since i
was young so like yeah that discipline
that fear of allah in your heart um has
been instilled in me since i've been
little and it's been you know it's an
easy thing but a hundred percent and i i
think that i think that's a interesting
thing that happens a lot of people too
and i respect them so much more than
even people like myself who've been born
into it is when people
on their own go out and seek it and they
come to that conclusion on their own and
they they realize on their own all right
you know
alhamdulillah even if they're living
good lives if they live in a difficult
life they realize like there must be
more than just what's going on now you
know and they come to that conclusion on
their own and they're able to kind of
turn it around it's a lot more difficult
than it is for someone like me who's
been
born into it and who's never had you
know much struggles i've been blessed
with parents that have taken care of us
and stuff so like you know i
if i was doing anything else it would be
it would be
it would it'd be harder for me to
be on the wrong path than the right one
so like yeah you know i
back to what i said earlier too about
people that i've seen like around me
that have so much success whatever and
they're missing something um it's just
taking a second to take a step back and
like
facing that you know a lot of people
don't like to face that feeling and
that's why they continue to
party and drink and do drugs and stuff
because it's easier than sitting there
and and kind of having that inner
conversation with yourself and like
what's missing here i have all the money
i wanted i have all the success i
reached all my goals i know like what's
missing people don't want to have that
conversation with themselves but i think
when people do
um
a lot of the time maybe it's this it's
some sort of faith at least that that uh
they realize is what's missing and i
believe it's it's hard honestly i can't
imagine living this life and thinking
that when i die it's just done like i
can't imagine
i wouldn't be able to comprehend that it
makes sense you know like it would be
hard for me to see
people dying and your family and to go
through all these hard times and to feel
like you know
one like this is it and two i'm not
gonna
like be like these people are not gonna
be account accounted accountable for
what they did to me for example you know
i've had some tough experiences in
business and stuff where i'm like you
know what i'm easy like i'm good knowing
that allah takes count of everything and
i'll get back whatever i deserve at some
point and like like again like it's just
so much better than living a life
without
that that um
that belief because it i just would not
be able to take so many things on a
day-to-day basis if i didn't know that
you know it's all going to come
a full circle at some point inshallah
when we stand in front of allah and i'm
sure we're going to have other things to
worry about than one guy wrong in us but
you know it's like it's a good peace of
mind and alhamdulillah makes sense so
i've i've had so many opportunities to
sit with people also who are in the
limelight and one person comes to mind i
mentioned him a little earlier loon and
there's a statement by him he said we
were paying for the disease while the
cure was free
so what would you say to many of the
youth people who are into gaming
and they can relate to you
and you know they might be tempted
they're like they're inquisitive or
they're tempted to go and accept
invitation to the nightclub yeah go hang
out and you know possibly they're going
to be around other people who are
passing around the joints yeah you know
what other things that can come with it
the drugs and whatnot and and they're
close to slipping but they're listening
to you right and they're thinking and
many people have warned look there's
nothing out there you're gonna it's like
a broken bridge you're gonna fall off
right so what would you say yeah so
that's that's where it gets tough for me
um
when you see people partaking in certain
things people that you're not super
close with right but that are muslim and
stuff and like
it's hard like i try to walk a walk that
line carefully of like
you know i don't want to make any
comments or say thanks to people that
will push them even further you know
it's it's always a tricky thing and we
see that in our communities people think
that they're helping and they make
things a lot worse and
it's listen
to my close friends and stuff that i've
talked to that have dabbled into like
the world that i've dabbled into it's
like people that i'm really close with i
say it very straight to them like don't
even think about
opening that door to any haram money um
and even with that like again i don't
sound hypocritical because even myself
like i've had a recently realized like i
used to have a lot of music in my videos
and stuff like that and like it kind of
hit me like a train at some point where
i was like wait a minute like
i never thought about this being haram
and you know allah adam inshallah
allah knows best of how he's going to
deal with all those things but like i
even had that realization recently i was
like all right and i did what i you know
i took my steps in my personal way of
talking to some people and figure out
what i should do to try to like you know
do what i can to repair that but like
when it comes to opening the door with
obvious haram like like uh gambling
sponsors or or drinking sponsors or like
you said even drinking and or falling
into peer pressure or people try to give
you a drink and stuff like that like
yeah it's not of course it's not worth
it and there'll be no blessings in
anything you do if if you're getting off
if you're getting into a new industry
and like you start off on the wrong foot
like why would allah put anybody in or
blessings in your money and your success
you know what i'm saying like you know
it's it's it's just it's just obviously
something that is not going to help you
out in this life or the next maybe in
the moment um someone will think you you
know help you with like a personal
relationship but like dude in this world
in business what i've another thing i've
realized i'm not i don't act like i'm
the most experienced person i'm young
but i'm that i've had a lot of years of
working with people and like
at some point
a lot of people will flip on you either
way no matter if you do all the things
to make it right for them and like
people really are out here for
themselves it's happened a lot or like
i've been shocked at
at people kind of stabbing us in the
back and even personally just it's just
never worth it no human is gonna be
worth making allah angry with you and
that's just
that's just how it is that that's just
the fact at the end of the day and like
these small things that might help
further your career now
you might think may help further your
career now are going to come back and
collapse it later and
there's just
i don't know i just think there's
like i mentioned there's way more
blessing in staying away from haram and
it'll be replaced with better and
you know i think people also respect
these days when
if you're like i'm muslim i don't drink
like
people respect that
and i think you know you can lean into
that a little more and like it's it's
better to stand by who you are and your
in your uh
and like you know your your morals and
your
standards you set for yourself than
caving into what what other people like
and even on even on a business level i i
really think people respect that more
than
than they even would have you wouldn't
impress them by drinking but people like
okay like they can respect you staying
away from it you know
but at the end of the day it's all about
making allah happy and
you know we know what's wrong and what
we shouldn't do and we should just do
our best to stay away from it beautiful
i love it you got to stand for something
or fall for anything and you're standing
for some one of the most beautiful
things and that's your deen this way of
life
that brings you that contentment that
peace that money can't buy
and tell us about this uh this is younow
yeah
yeah what do you think uh tell us about
where does it for someone like snoop
dogg or some of these athletes they they
don't know where this is at and you
think maybe you can plan a trip you know
you can invite someone to come visit so
they can see firsthand like what's going
on in this part of the world yeah so
this is in jerusalem in palestine at
well that's
technically the whole complex is
measured that's that's called the dome
of the rock though and that's a very
important
uh spot and i think all three major
religions and islam that's where the
night ascension was with the prophet
a lot of prophets a lot of people in the
history of our religion have been in
that area and been around there but very
that's the third holiest site in our
religion
in islam and uh yeah i'm i'm palestinian
like i mentioned uh and i never really
visited till
2017. um
so
again even that like i kind of just grew
up as like an american kid um kind of
detached from my culture even the
language as well um the last couple
years i've really put in some work and i
still have a lot of work to do to learn
the language better for multiple reasons
but uh
yeah i love palestine i wish i could
go as much as i could kind of
at this point you know my parents are
really scared of me even going to visit
because i've posted so much about it uh
last time i was there i got stopped you
know and my phone got looked through at
the at the israeli border and stuff like
that it's not the simplest thing for
pals for palestinians to go visit and
you know like i mentioned about me kind
of realizing my platform for
um spreading the message of islam i
realized the same thing for
uh
spreading you know awareness of what's
happening and obviously palestine hits
home to me because i'm full palestinian
and there's a lot of things that are
happening around the world that should
have awareness spread to them and
unfortunately a lot of other things
don't get as much light
spread on them but like for me i'm
palestinian something that i really you
know care about and this affected my
family and
i love it i love palestine and i love
you know the last year there was a lot
unfortunately going on during ramadan um
and you know i realized that i had to
use my platform for good even recently
actually
uh it's kind of uh
i probably shouldn't be talking about it
because it kind of caused a little bit
of issues for for me and some of my
friends but some of my friends were
visiting um
with some co-workers that are israeli um
some of my friends were visiting and i
kind of posted about it and you know
it's just one of those things where i
feel like uh i'm trying to
one educate myself a little more on on
what's gone on in the conflict and to
educate the people around me so even my
friends
that are not israeli like i'm talking
about like my friends just
from brazil and from wherever they're
that we're visiting i you know i kind of
had some conversations with them letting
them know hey
you know i don't blame you for not
knowing but like
you know there's a lot going on there
and you should kind of know and you know
they know i'm palestinian or whatever so
like
it's i'm trying to learn for myself and
i'm trying to learn to also you know
help spread some awareness because
historically palestinians have not
really had a voice um
in like mainstream media i guess you'd
say again and like this
you know how it is you know a lot of
people have been scared to speak on it
even myself i kind of every time i post
i'm kind of like well i don't know if
this is gonna hurt me later in the
future with
me trying to visit or you know with
business i don't know but like again
back to what i said like i really don't
care because i think it's uh i'm more
scared of facing allah and him telling
me why didn't you
use your platform to spread this you
know and like i i don't want to act like
i'm saying that now and i hope i can
live by that you know but i know it's
not the easiest thing for other people
as well so
it's just kind of like
i'm just kind of at this point in my
life at least i'm kind of just like hey
i gotta do what i gotta do whatever
happens happens and i know that i'll
guide us towards whatever so like when i
see an opportunity that i have to speak
out on it i do and uh
yeah that's that's what that was and i'm
trying to again educate myself a little
more and
when times to talk about the times talk
about it so
yeah i've been around a lot of fighters
you know i teach for a living martial
arts and uh oh wow okay no i didn't know
that i mean i've i've been i've seen
your show for years now by the way and
congratulations on everything and the
new message that i saw recently michelle
or the new center i guess
uh
but i didn't know that i didn't know the
martial arts thing which is awesome i
gotta take some lessons from you
yeah inshallah when you come down to
chicago yeah we're working on we're
trying to open up the dean's center yeah
we're working on towards that my point
when i was what i wanted to say was that
i've been around you know a lot of tough
individuals
but some are actually when it comes down
to this what you're saying
this true bravery
courage is what you're doing because you
can be a fighter you can be somebody
who's a champion ufc but when it comes
down to standing because you're out
there and you're getting all the
uh hoorays and all of the props and
that's feeding your ego and your desire
and you're just feeling great but what
are you doing with that at the end of
the day right when it's time to go ahead
and stand for something
like muhammad ali did like malcolm x did
like some of the giants who are
remembered today many of these people
are scared they're cowards yeah and i
really commend you for that for having
such a big platform and you're actually
talking the way you're talking no i
appreciate it but honestly
like i haven't even done anything
compared to what i should have done and
should be doing and
at least for me that's what i'm trying
to just start you know i'm trying to try
to do something and inshallah lead i'm
sure i'm able to do a lot more than i am
now but i i appreciate it i mean number
one thing for me is again educating
myself so i actually know what i'm
talking about and i'm not just following
trends there's a lot of people on the
internet do and obviously like i said
the palestinian
i don't want to call it a conflict the
palestinian occupation
situation is something that hits a lot
closer to home because my dad was there
in the in the 60s when you know he went
hiding in the mountains when they were
invading our village so like it's
you know i have to i have to who's going
to speak on it if we don't and like i
said there's a lot of other things that
are happening like with the with the
uyghurs and the you know a lot of people
around the world and
you know i i try not to like overwhelm
myself
because the way i am i was like all
right if i do this that means i have to
do this and i have to do that or
whatever and then i end up not doing
anything so like for me i'm just trying
to and you know at least a couple posts
at least a couple interviews like this
inshallah like
if i can just start doing a little bit
and shall it lead to me being able to do
a lot more and a lot of us can band
together and do a lot together and ham
did i think that's another thing that's
been really inspiring to me is like
since i've posted anything a lot of
other like muslim influencer
i don't look at myself as an influencer
but other like people on social media
basically muslim people that do social
media and stuff like that or
palestinians have reached out and like
you know like kind of reap like even
you're talking about fighters blah
muhammad the ufc fighter like me and him
kind of like
became good friends based on both of us
posting about palestine a lot and he's
palestinian and like we bonded over that
other like people as well like just
seeing that we're muslim i know it's you
know you know how it is like it's it's
cool when you meet another muslim
there's like this special connection so
like there's that and the throne on top
of being palestinian too like and
supporting the cause you know like it's
cool it's been it's been cool it's been
a blessing to like meet people and it
just inspires you to want to do more and
again habib i have to give all the
credit in the world to him like i think
he's the guy that
really made me like all right wait what
am i doing here i love being muslim and
i'm proud of being muslim and i want to
talk about it because seeing what he did
he did he is i know our generation's
muhammad ali and he really like for me
at least he kicked that door wide open
and i'm like okay he made me even more
proud to to be muslim so you know
there's people that are doing a lot more
than i am and that we are and i'm just
trying to follow in their footsteps
inshallah so masha'allah
very nice to hear just a couple more
questions before we conclude tell me
you now suffered a little bit of
backlash so you got a lot of support a
little bit of backlash but sometimes
just a little bit to have somebody
crumble and just you know go in the
shell and not come out again was it
worth it at the end and for somebody out
there some celebrity someone has a big
following they're also
watching us and they're also getting
motivated but they're worried and you
know you can't please everybody yeah so
you had some some people yeah some
things how'd you deal with it and what
would you say was it worth it at the end
yeah so i and i'm referring to this post
the post that you made
this one here beautiful prose again
you're at the first house of worship
built by abraham to commemorate the
worship of one and only one god this is
it mecca so this is what you did yeah
and you just you invited people to go
ahead and have a relationship with the
created heavens and earth and some
people said some things so how was that
yeah yeah so you know again i've been
making i've been pretty like on social
media because if i'm let me just i'm
sorry to interrupt you because you you
went into a shell if i understood the
first time this happened you were
younger exactly yeah and you experienced
somewhat some bullying and some insults
what were those insults and what and
then you kind of like you you were timid
to speak up again no hundred percent so
that's what i was going to say is like
how did i have been lucky now with 11
years of experience online like yeah
when i was first 14 years old and that's
my first three four or five months in
this world to be kind of like shot down
by again one of the leading figures in
the industry at the time oh your mom
wears a scarf on her head and he's
laughing like that
like i didn't know how to deal with it i
was leading a leading figure in industry
was mocking like this yeah like i meant
like the example i gave earlier like
imagine i joined i joined psg and messi
was making fun of my mom for wearing
hijab like that's exactly what jordan
who ps1 psg uh the soccer team psg
messi okay or like let you know messi is
like one of the most famous soccer give
me my my generation like jordan
exactly you join the bulls and michael
jordan is is just
you know coming at you for being your
name is yusef haha your mom wears a
scarf huh that's exactly what happened
so like i a little kid joining face clan
it was like a little basketball fan
joining the bulls exactly like that and
the michael jordan of our team was
coming at me so as a 14 year old
of course i went in my shell completely
like you said so
um again it comes with age it comes with
maturing and stuff for me to kind of
break out of that shell but even more
you know even more recently it's like i
mentioned it was because of someone like
habib like someone else showing how it
needs to be done and like then i kind of
had this realization what am i doing
like you know the last couple years i
wasn't like scared or wasn't it wasn't
even like that i just didn't think about
it um but at first definitely i think
back to your question about like the the
criticism that i've got that post
specifically the
about me being muslim i didn't really
get much i mean i didn't notice like i
said i've been doing this for like 11
years now so like i don't even read
comments anymore hate comments like i
genuinely i'm glad don't feel anything
when i read a comment about like the
only thing i care about is my family and
i have kept them completely
private and away from the internet for
that reason so like someone could say
whatever they want about me it really
doesn't affect me um i think the
palestinian stuff
the palestine stuff kind of was the more
shaky thing that kind of
you know could have caused some
disruption in my life and some problems
and like
i have to just be honest for me
um it's a lot easier for me to make
these
uh i guess quote unquote risky
statements and posts because like like
i'm i'm one of the founders of my
company i'm one of the owners of the
company and like
you know it doesn't mean i'm in i have
like immunity to anything happening to
me but
it's my company you know and like it's
i'm not gonna get kicked out for
speaking on my people being you know uh
being oppressed um it definitely can
cause problems but then it's a lot
harder for someone like me to get pushed
out of my position than it might be from
for other people so i just got to be
honest it's you know i i i don't want to
make it sound like everyone should be
doing this and that like everyone has
their own situation and story and
everyone can make change in their own
way but for me i'm you know it's a
little easier for me to just speak on
what i want to speak on without uh
having to really worry um but with that
being said
now in 2022
you know everyone knows the culture's a
little different it's a little uh
you could say one wrong thing and you
can be absolutely canceled
for the rest of your life and that might
happen i don't know we'll just see what
the next couple years uh are like with
me but like it's like i said i have a
little more of protection one and two
like
um
i'm you know i'm definitely i'm
definitely not
where i want to be i'm not like acting
like i'm can retire tomorrow and but
like i'm i'm currently setting myself up
inshallah i'm trying even with my
company right even if something was to
happen to me i own the company i still
own shares in the company and stuff like
that and like my life's not going to be
over i'm not going to be completely out
of work for example if i was to be
you know pushed out of any position or
whatever so again i just want to make
that distinction clear like it is easier
for me you know so like i can't blame
other people for not speaking as much
but like that's why i really am not
scared of anyone
coming at me for speaking my mind is
because like they can't really you know
i i'm this is my company one of the
other founders with me is also
palestinian as well and like you know
it's just it is what it is and if people
if if the time comes where there's some
pressure and there's some you know
there's a there's a point where i have
to like kind of choose between the two
sides and i'm just going to do what i
got to do for me and you know and that
i'm that i'm
that that will put me in a vision where
i'm um
okay with taking whatever i'm doing to
allah and whatever happens happens so
and sorry i kind of
didn't explain that well but my my main
point is that like
i'm i'm in a lot easier position than
other people are and like that's why i
gotta just i gotta say what i gotta say
because
not everyone has that opportunity so
and what you're saying is alhamdulillah
you're praising the most high just like
habib did you live in the way of jesus
of moses abraham and you're trying to
live a morally upright life and i'm sure
many parents you know would love to have
their kids quit drinking alcohol doing
drugs so the message is a positive
message it's a message that helps
helps deliver change and helps deliver
that good that comes from that change
and i think if more people accept this
uh like the snoop doggy dogs
it's it's it's the house of peace so
inviting people to the house of peace i
don't think there should be any
objection to that now people are free to
do whatever they want but this is the
solution to antidote for many if not all
the social ill i think you're right that
point just real fast
that's also a main thing i know i'm not
i know everything i'm saying is is good
and positive and i'm not saying anything
wrong and i'm not you know like
i
that's why i'm so comfortable speaking
my mind because i know what's right is
what i'm saying and you're right 100 i'm
pushing a positive
message and even like i have told you a
lot of the guys that i know that
have come to me over the years i know i
can see why you don't drink after
drinking the whole night before and i
can see why you don't do this and
alhamdulillah you know it's that's not
me it's islam and and
i think people like are just not exposed
to the fact that people live life away
from these things so yeah
yeah
there's nothing to hide when you're
pushing a positive message anyways
that's phase apex here on the dean show
thank you for being with us my young
brother thank you so much i appreciate
you having me
my god almighty allah the creator
continue to bless you preserve you and
use you for this demon all of us
inshallah thank you so much
and that was our brother apex i want to
thank you young brother for being on the
d show he's running one of the biggest
gaming organizations in the world and we
could take a
few good lessons from this young man one
what helps him to be so disciplined
what helps him to stay with salah
establishing that connect direct
connection with his creator five times a
day minimum in salah
and where other people are drinking and
doing drugs and life's upside down he's
not deviating from that he's got the
courage to invite others to it and
that's what we're inviting you to also
something that can help snoop doggy
doggy and all the other famous
celebrities out there the johnny depps i
mean these are people who have a big
influence but you can see you know
people are chasing their desires and
they forget about the reality of death
they forget about the reality of what
comes after this life and they just put
money as the number one target fame is
the number one target but at the end of
the day all this stuff does not give the
heart what it needs there will always be
a void and you cannot fill that void
with all of these things and expect the
pain to go away you can numb it like
many do
by doing all the drugs and the partying
and
just listening to the music day and
night bobbing your head to the 50 cents
and the snoopies and whatnot
at the end of the day
you're gonna die
and this is this young brothers thinking
ahead smart individual to think about
these things how many young boys young
men young women are thinking about these
very important questions what's the
purpose of life why am i here
so if you can go ahead and ponder over
some advice he was giving what we
started off with if you're missing that
piece of contentment and purpose in life
look into this beautiful way of life and
i got some for you
you can visit thedeenshow.com to get a
free copy of the quran and if you still
have any questions call us
1-800-662-islam we'll see you next time
and also make sure to uh support our
project that's coming up we're trying to
establish the dean center masjid mega
dawa center so make sure that you go
ahead and contribute be a part of
history where we have over 300 million
americans and the majority they don't
know what islam is they don't know what
islam is submission to the creator not
the creations we're going to be helping
to educate because education is key you
got so much negative propaganda and hate
out there we're trying to combat that
with the proper knowledge that people
need so they have a better understanding
and inshallah they can also go ahead
and gain what he gained and what we were
talking about so we'll see you next time
here on the dean show
thank you very much for tuning in until
then peace be with you assalamu alaikum
this is your brother hamza andreas
and i want every single one of you to
support eddie from the dean show
financially and otherwise but in what
way
i want you to support his new project
the deen center it's going to be a
transformative experience this center
why because it's going to be a masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a daower
center to call people back to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala muslims and
non-muslims and we trust eddie
completely i for one will take a
thousand bullets for eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the tower he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many dua and preachers
and scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the deancenter.org
donate now
[Music]